alan dershowitz is no stranger to
high-profile and controversial clients
he advised OJ Simpson's defense team and
he represented convicted pedophile
Jeffrey Epstein too now he's getting
ready to help Donald Trump at the Senate
impeachment trial but he was torn about
doing it and he wasn't the only one
my wife had great reluctance and in the
end President Trump spoke to my wife and
my wife made the arguments why I
shouldn't do it and we've had to think
this through very hard as a as a family
I'm a liberal Democrat I voted against
President Trump the Harvard Law
professor is focusing solely on a
constitutional argument not evidence I
will argue that the two articles of
impeachment don't satisfy the
constitutional criteria the
constitutional criteria are treason
nobody has alleged that he's committed
treason bribery although there's been
discussion abrir he wasn't charged with
that or other high crimes and
misdemeanors I interpret other high
crimes and misdemeanors to require
criminal conduct not abuse of power so
are you arguing that even if he has done
something which some people might regard
as wrong it is not impeachable there's
no doubt that he's done many things that
many people regard as wrong but the law
distinguishes between sin and crime do
you think it is fundamentally wrong
asking a foreign power to investigate a
political rival yes and if there were
firm evidence of that that would be a
good reason why people should cast a
vote against the person who did that but
I'm not here to argue the conflicting
evidence Donald Trump wants to testify
do you think he should know all of my
clients want to testify all the time
they want to tell their story but it's
far better to let the prosecution in
this case the house put on their case
and then let it be rebutted is it
because you think Donald Trump is a weak
witness No
I think that Donald Trump would fill in
gaps that's what happens good
prosecutors asked questions and lay
perjury traps but what about other
witnesses like left honest an associate
of Rudy Giuliani who recently said the
president knew all about the pressure
campaign in Ukraine in the end a lot of
his statements on television or hearsay
or double hearsay but I have no problem
with witnesses coming on if the Senate
decides they want to hear witnesses on
both sides as you say you've represented
lots of highly controversial clients why
are you drawn to those cases I grew up
in Brooklyn as a street kid following
the Holocaust many of my family died in
the Holocaust I want to live in a
country where everybody is always
defended what's the last thing the
president has said to you good luck
do you think you'll need it of course
this week he will make his case on the
Senate floor
he believes obstruction of Congress
isn't even an impeachable offense but
whatever he says it seems highly likely
the president will stay in office would
Elia Lynch Sky News Miami